good afternoon welcome to the third
session today in the afternoon so it
looks like we will have a session about
quantum algorithms and complexity which
talk by three innovation I do not sure I
mean run either both and see an assembly
Coughlin's everyone thanks for coming
I'm going to talk about sample
complexity of learning algorithms and
this is joint work with my adviser
Ronald the wolf so let me begin by
talking about just machine learning so
the grand goal in machine learning is to
enable AI systems to improve themselves
this is a big statement and this is also
ambitious so something practical that we
want to settle for is can we learn
something from a given data suppose you
have a cluster of information can we
make predictions communique and future
patterns and so on in recent years
machine learning has received an
enormous boost from the success of deep
learning deep learning is extremely good
at image recognition natural language
processing and even the game go and why
is there a sudden interest in this field
it's because there's a flood of
available data this is increasing
computational power and the algorithms
community we are coming up with better
algorithms for machine learning tasks so
what's in it for us
what can quantum computing do for
machine learning so here I mean I just
want to clarify something we can also
have the data we have is classical and
we feed it to a quantum computer or the
data may also be quantum now indeed we
do know of tasks for which there's a
reduction in time complexity for example
the k-means clustering problem the
principal component analysis the
perceptron learning and even the
recommendation system paper that we saw
presented earlier today so starting
problems on its own is interesting but
what we are interested in this talk is
can we have a framework of learning that
has been mathematically rigorously
analyzed and which captures some aspects
of machine learning and what I'll be
talking about is the back model of law
this is very well studied in
computational learning theory and it is
fairly simple to explain so pakistan's
were probably approximately correct so
before I get to describing the model of
computation there are some basic
definitions we need to get ourselves
I could ourselves equipped to it so
concept class is a collection of boolean
functions on n bits we restrict
ourselves to boolean functions for
simplicity and this collection of
boolean functions could come from low
depth circuits may be or may be
functions computed by DN f formulas and
so on a target concept is some function
from the concept loss and a distribution
D is the distribution on all n bit
strings and a labelled example for a
target concept C is a tuple X comma C of
X where X is drawn according to the
distribution D so back model of learning
has a very formal rigorous definition
but before I get to that let me explain
what a back learning algorithm looks
like here
pac-man is my PAC learner we have a
concept class script C that is a
collection of boolean functions that is
known to pac-man he doesn't know the
target concept though and naturally what
you want him to do is maybe come somehow
try to find out what the target concept
is and the way the learning process goes
is you first speaker x1 sampled
according to the distribution and give
pac-man X comma C of X so now he knows
something about the target concept but
this is not too much yet so he says I
want some more examples he gets another
x2 and he sees x2 comma C of X 2 and so
on and we repeat this process until he
sees T examples and at some point he
says yeah ok I'm good now and he outputs
a hypotheses H and something natural
that we hope for is maybe with
probability 99% he outputs a hypothesis
H which is close to the target concept
and this 99% is precisely what probably
is referring to here and is
approximately correct I'll get to in a
bit but this 99% then approximately
correct is precisely what's captured by
that probably approximately correct so
let me give you a formal definition
so Leslie Valiant introduced this model
in
1984 in a seminal paper a theory of the
learnable so using highly labeled
examples a learner should output I
potus's H that is probably approximately
correct in the sense that we just saw so
let me first tell you what approximately
correct means so in a standard way if
you have two boolean functions you would
say H and C are close to one another
what and you would define close by
saying what is the probability the
probability that H and C differ on some
X but here what I mean by error is I
mean the probability that these two the
concept and the hypotheses differ is
measured according to an unknown
distribution D so this X is sample
according to D and D is an unknown
distribution so we say a pacman is an
epsilon Delta learner if for every
concept and the concept clause and for
every distribution D on n bit strings
with probability 1 minus Delta he can
output a hypothesis that's close to the
target concept again so the point is you
fix her concept which he doesn't know
you fix a distribution which he again
doesn't know but the point is with
probability 1 minus Delta he should
output a hypothesis that is close to the
target concept and this close is
measured according to the distribution D
and that is what is approximately
correct
and that is precisely the formal
definition of how back model looks like
so what is a good notion of complexity
measure kind of I've alluded to one
notion of complexity measure already in
my pac-man drawing at a sample
complexity there is a number of labeled
examples that the pac-man sees another
natural notion of complexity measure is
time complexity the amount of time steps
that he uses maybe in processing the
data and outputting hypotheses and so on
in this talk I'll restrict myself to
just sample complexity just analyzing
sample complexity has a fair bit of
advantages the first one is there is no
need for complexity theoretical
assumptions we are just working with
information theoretic quantities
secondly you know you do you don't need
to worry on the format in which the
hypothesis is presented from pac-man and
the most important point this classical
sample complexity has been very well
analyzed in machine learning literature
and we know that it is characterized by
a combinatorial parameter called the VC
dimension so let me tell you what this
combinatorial parameter is so B C stands
for APNIC and German and kiss and okay
you have a concept plus but the
consensus of consists of a set of
boolean functions let's just say for
each boolean function I write this truth
table the size of the truth table is of
size 2 to the N and I stack all the
truth tables of all the concepts in a
table so you have a matrix M which is
boolean firstly and secondly it has size
size of the Khans concept plus cross 2
to the N where the seat row of this
table is a truth table of concept see
now the VC dimension is the largest set
of columns in this matrix such that if
you restrict your attention to these D
columns it contains all possible D bit
strings it takes a minute for this
definition to sink in so let me give you
an example and just for notational
convenience I will say this D column
indices are shattered by the concept
loss so let us say we are looking at
little n equal to 2 so
boolean functions on two bits and the
truth table has size for now let's just
say there let's just say there are nine
concepts and you have a concept class on
two bits now if you look at just the
four if you look at the first and third
column those are the red columns and if
you look at the first four concepts you
see 0 0 0 1 1 0 1 1 and that is
precisely what the VC dimension asks you
you want them so this is at least so the
VC dimension is at least 2 because I can
give you explicitly 2 columns such that
if you restrict to the rectangle on
these two columns you obtain all
possible 2 bit strings and I've
constructed it this example in such a
way that if I add a third column
I couldn't have obtained 3 bit strings
but here's another example so this
example is again on 2 bits
it has 9 concepts and if you look at the
last three columns you should be able to
see all possible 3 bit strings yeah I'm
not going to wait for you to figure that
out but it's it's you see all possible 3
bit strings so what is nice about this
VC dimension so it's the following
so the fundamental theorem of PAC
learning states the following suppose
you have a concept class with VC
dimension D then Blumer at all showed in
86 that every epsilon Delta pac-man
needs to use at least D or Epsilon
examples to learn in the car to learn
the concept loss and they proved an
upper bound that was worse by log 1 over
epsilon factor and until last year this
factor was not removed and steve hanneke
showed that for every concept class
there exists a learner who also uses D
or epsilon examples to learn the concept
clause so in some sense I mean what is
you began my talk with was some form of
a learning complexity number of labeled
examples to satisfy some condition and
then I had some combinatorial parameter
Spira combinatorial you have a concept
plus which is known this compute the VC
dimension and I'm saying this
combinatorial parameter characterizes
the learning complexity so for every
concept class that I give you if I just
tell you the VC dimension that
characterizes
the back sample complexity that's why
it's kind of beautiful so let's go to
quantum pack learning so what can
quantum computers do for pack learning
so first for some what I mean by quantum
in fact in fact learning so shooting in
Jackson and 95 looked at this problem
and they define a natural generalization
of a labelled example and they call it a
quantum example this is essentially a
superposition of label examples where
the amplitudes are given by the
distribution and in am I mean this is
like most natural generalization that we
can hope for from the classical pack
model and how a quantum pack learning
algorithm looks like is quantum pac-man
that guy right there this guy he sees
different he continuously keeps in
quantum examples it's like a coherent
coherently some process is providing us
quantum examples and end of the day he
again needs to satisfy the standard
definition that he needs to learn the
concept class concept see so one way to
see why this is a generalization of the
classical model is suppose we choose to
measure it so when you measure it you
see a tuple X comma C of X where X comes
from the distribution D and this is
precisely how I defined my classical
pack model and this at least shows that
quantum examples are at least as
powerful as classical examples so can we
hope for so we hope for something more
so at least there are at least as
powerful as classical examples can we
hope where they are much more powerful
and indeed they are quantum examples are
indeed more powerful for learning if you
look at the class of linear functions
and if you look at the distribution D we
know that classically you need at least
and classical examples to learn the
class of linear functions but quantumly
a constant number of examples suffice
and this is due to the Bernstein was a
learning algorithm if you look at a
class of DNF formulas again on the
uniform distribution the best-known
upper bound classically is
quasi-polynomial time and quantumly the
best-known upper bound is polynomial
time so kind of we're done here
my question was the quantum examples
provide an advantage
and kind of I've kind of answered it and
yeah that should be good for now but
there's a problem in the pack model or
Lorna has to succeed for every
distribution D and the examples that I
looked at here they only succeed for the
uniform distribution D so there's we
still haven't answered the question
this quantum held back learning so let's
look at quantum sample complexity the
complexity measure associated with the
quantum pack model so quantum upper
bound comes directly from the classical
upper bound because the quantum examples
are at least as powerful as the
classical examples and Steve Hanaka did
the hard work for us he proved an upper
bound of D or epsilon so we are good for
now for quantum lower bounds the
previous best known lower bond was where
a teachings for radio they proved a
lower bound of square root D or Epsilon
and sank using similar techniques as
what they did he proved an lower banner
he improved the first time to D to the 1
minus ETA for constant ETA and what we
shown our work is a tight lower bound we
show you need your epsilon quantum
examples to learn a concept loss to
learn a concept loss now I want to
highlight this a little bit more in the
previous slide we saw an example where
you get a one was this end separation
for a distribution D and kind of when we
started this project we were hoping at
least to get a log D improvement in for
when you needed to succeed for every
distribution but kind of what we show
now is you cannot get any improvement if
you need the learner to succeed for
every distribution D so quantum sample
complexity is equal to classical sample
complexity of the constant factors and
kind of the way we prove this is by we
have to proof approaches one is
information theoretic it's fairly simple
but the point is we get nearly tight
bounds and we use another technique it's
called the optimal measurements and we
get tight bounds using this method but
it involves some messy calculations so
the next two slides I'm going to talk
about optimal measurements and convince
you that we have a lower bound of D over
Epsilon
so let me first begin by talking on the
state identification problem we have an
ensemble of M States so I want to say m
and each of them are associated with the
probability P 1 2 p.m. in the state
identification problem you're given a
state cycie from the ensemble with
probability P Z and your goal is
identified Z fairly straightforward and
what will you do you get a state you do
a POV M you get an outcome we output the
outcome that is kind of what you would
do and what you need to do is maximize
over the set of all measurements so that
you can see what is the optimal success
probability for this ensemble but that
could be complicated because you're
maximizing or a lot of measurements what
happened up here we have something
called a pretty good measurement it's
pretty good actually
what's good about it is the following
suppose the optimal success probability
is called P odd then obviously the
success probability of the PGM is at
most a success probability of the
optimal measurement now what's
interesting is the fact that this cannot
be too small this is at least the
optimal success probability square so so
far so good
we know state agentic state
identification problem and we know a way
to handle it
but what is all this got to do with
learning I mean I was talking and
learning for so long and suddenly I'm
talking of state identification so on
the quantum pack model what we get is we
receive T T copies of the quantum
example State and our goal is to learn a
concept approximately not clearly you
can see that here I'm talking of here
again I'm talking MC approximately and
here I'm talking of identifying Z and
the remaining part of the slide I want
to say that you can go from learning a
concept approximately to identify
something about the concept which is
going to be of which is going to be of
use to us again remember the goal the
goal is to show that the sample
complexity that is T is at least a VC
dimension divided by epsilon so let us
say the VC dimension of the concept loss
is d plus 1 for simplicity and because
we're looking at lower bounds we can fix
a distribution of our choice I'm going
to fix a hard distribution and I'm gonna
say quantum pac-man for this
distribution needs to make well he's a
lot of exam
and so I'm gonna fix a heart
distribution a distribution that puts
almost its entire weight on the on the
first shattered in the index and almost
uniform weight from s 1 to s D and yes
one more idea that we need is a concept
of error correcting codes we take a
constant rate constant relative distance
or a correcting code so essentially this
is um you can view this as a map that
takes the K bit string to a D bit string
such that if you look at G of X G of Y
and G of Z the constant distance between
these two code words is at least a
constant sorry the relative distance is
at least a constant so that's good and
now what we're going to do is I'm gonna
get a little bit more technical as I'm
gonna get pick a bunch of concepts in my
concept class pick two to the K concepts
from a concept plus there are defined in
this funny way so I'm gonna pick a
concept such that on s 0 its 0 and on
the remaining so the point is we had D
plus 1 points on s 0 the concept is
going to be 0 and the remaining D points
is going to be a code word now if you're
kind of losing me here I'm gonna explain
this a little bit more clearly now again
how am I going to pick these concepts
sorry so suppose the VC dimension of the
concept class was D plus 1 what does
that mean if you look at these D plus 1
columns and if you look at the rectangle
of this D plus 1 columns you should have
obtained all possible D plus 1 bit
strings and let us say this is the truth
table of my concept so as 0 2 as the
other column indices and if you look at
the rectangle this entire rectangle it
contains everything from 0 to the D plus
1 all the way up to 1 to the D plus 1
and because I needed that term on 0 the
concept was 0 I'm going to discuss all
the black concepts sorry I'm gonna pick
all the blue concepts firstly and
secondly what I'm gonna do is on s 1 to
s D I want the concept to be a code word
so the point is we had this error
correcting code E and we have 2 to the K
code words
that is for all the evaluations of e on
K bit strings and I'm going to pick two
to the K concepts or to the D concepts
such that all these these concepts on
these D points are precisely code words
so what am i doing I'm doing a lot of
funny things I talk about state
identification I'm talking of learning
that I'm talking error correction what's
crucial is the following by my choice of
concepts by my choice of a distribution
I can actually show that learning the
set of concepts approximately with
respect to my heart distribution is
equivalent to identifying the K bit
string Z so that's really the crux here
the whole point of this error correcting
code and the choice of my concepts is to
say that learning something
approximately is equivalent to
identifying a K bit string z and now we
are in good shape because we know how to
handle the state identification problem
using a pretty good measurement maybe so
learning a concept approximately is
equivalent to identifying Z so suppose
the sample complexity is T that means
that if there is a good learner who
receives T quantum examples I know the
probability is e identify with
probability one minus Delta identifies Z
and remove the goal again the goal is to
show that T is at least deep do your
epsilon and kind of now because we are
in the state identification picture we
can look at the pretty good measurement
so suppose we consider this ensemble of
2 to the K States equipped with the
uniform distribution what we have is
that the success probability of the
pretty good measurement is at least the
squared success probability of the
optimal measurement which we know is at
least 1 minus Delta because the PAC
sample complexity is T so it remains
simply upper bound the success
probability of the pretty good
measurement and that's sort of the meat
of the calculation is but we can show
that the success probability of the
pretty good measurement is at most this
expression here and in particular this
implies the T is at least D over Epsilon
kind of this is all the this is the
proof sketch there's if kind of you miss
what's going on what's going on was the
following you have the quantum pack
learning and you want to
one for that and you want to you want to
have a grip on the lower bounds so you
look at something which you kind of
understand better that's the state
identification problem and the
translation from quantum pack learning
the state identification is by first
fixing a hard distribution then fixing a
set of code fixing a set of concepts
which I call codeword concepts because
they come from an error correcting code
and then you use the pretty good
measurement and you get the lower bound
before I conclude I'm just going to talk
of one more model of learning which is
fairly interesting and more realistic
and that's the agnostic model of
learning so so far I mean in the back
model of learning we saw labeled the
pac-man and kept seeing labeled examples
of the form X comma C of X and we knew
that there exists a target concept C
coming from the concept plus button
early in a realistic machine learning
situation it could very well be that
there is no fixed target concept or
there could just be some noise in the
amount of information that you're
getting so how do we model this this has
been well studied and it's called
agnostic model of learning so you have
an unknown distribution D on a supporter
on n plus 1 bit strings that generates
examples of the form X comma L so you
have a label L associated with every n
bit string X and suppose you have a
concept class script C such that the
best concept that predicts this
distribution makes an error opt that is
if you look at the probability that X
comma L is drawn from the distribution
we see that the C makes me the
probability that C doesn't classify L is
equal to opt or it is the best predictor
that we have for the distribution D an
agnostic learning the goal is the
following you want to output a
hypothesis H that makes error at most
epsilon plus the best concept from the
concept plus kind of we have to see that
in a PAC model of learning this concept
class was coming in the starting where
we had a target concept was picked from
the concept class and you want to learn
the concept but in agnostic learning the
con
plus is where you want a hypothesis to
lie it is sort of more realistic in some
sense and what do we know about sample
complexity so we're showing that the
classical sample complexity is theta D
over epsilon D or epsilon square and
unlike the pack model we didn't know of
any quantum lower bounds for this model
of learning and what we showed in our
paper is that even if we have this
slightly more general model than pack
model quantum examples do not reduce
sample complexity so even in this more
slightly more realistic model of
learning quantum examples do not help
and that gets me to the end of my talk
so in conclusion what we showed is if
you look at the pack model of learning
and the agnostic model of learning
quantum examples and know better than
classical examples and we wanted to go
one step further and we looked at
something which which also machine
learning people care about that's a
model with random classification noise
and even in this model we show quantum
examples are no better than classical
examples so machine learning is pretty
young there's been a recent buzz in this
field for the past for the fires with
lot of papers in the field of quantizing
classical machine learning models but we
still don't have many convincing
examples where quantum significantly
improves classical machine learning
something in lines of what I've been
speaking about is and more theoretical
is can we look at more optimistic pack
light models the learner need not
succeed for every concept plus and for
every distribution because we know of a
concept plus a specific distribution for
which we know for one was this n
separation but once you enforce this for
all D kind of you lose all this speed-up
that you could have hoped for so can you
maybe put some restriction and hope that
quantum examples actually do help in the
quantum back model and with that I thank
you for your time
[Applause]
thank you for the nice dog we have time
for questions
hi thank you for the talk I'm curious
about what kinds of restrictions on the
distributions might be sort of realistic
or useful restrictions to make that you
think would still perhaps preserve hope
in quantum complexity yeah it's a good
question mm-hmm so what we know is for
the uniform distribution you have this
one was this n separation and you could
hope for a poly n was this exponential
and separation for the time complexity
not really sure whether I'm not sure
what to hope for I mean there could be
some distributions but I'm not sure what
they could be I guess the question maybe
is also is that are the problems or that
the sort of killer distributions are
they limited enough that they can be
sort of is there a sensible criteria
that screen them out
so it's possible but I don't know we
Ronald do you have any yeah I mean thank
you it's future work yeah
so in your lower bound you used these
air correcting codes can you say a few
words about why they were necessary or
useful for the the lower bound proof so
the idea is once you have this
once you fix this error correcting code
what's nice is if you look at the
distance between if you look at the
distance between two concepts when
measured according to the distribution D
the point is because these code words
these concepts are picked according to
the code words the distance so what was
closed earlier according to D should
have been identifying identified by
using this error correcting code so I
mean essentially what I'm saying is if
you look at the distance between two
concepts when you measure with respect
to the D because of the error correcting
code property the distance between them
is pretty large and we want a good
learner which implies that he should
have identified Z
so in these cases it's not just that you
could have all distributions but also
that you don't know in which
distribution you are particularly could
it help if you could still see all
distributions but as soon as the one is
fixed you would kind of give information
about the distribution to learn
I don't think about the question exactly
so like in this case is the learner
doesn't know anything about the
distribution I agree it may be like you
could have a learner that works for all
distributions but gets information of
the out of the distribution as well I
can ask how probable it is to get a
certain element Oh
[Music]
it's not really sure if you have an
answer
maybe Rahl has an answer
any other questions
yes my dear
sorry maybe I missed something so at the
beginning you said you had to proof
techniques right
so I guess that was one of them could
you say something about the other
technique maybe I could I can quickly go
through it maybe actually I'm not going
to spend time but all this quickly
sameen disproof approaches by
information-theoretic some in the way
you use the same way of you use the same
distribution which puts a lot of weight
on s0 that's the nasty distribution I've
been always looking at so if you have a
good learner you should have this
hypothesis should be a good weight
this concept is a viewed as a d-plus one
bit string and a good learner should
learn the D plus one string with he
should learn at least a constant number
of bits of the D plus one bit string so
if you just look at the mutual
information between so I mean you can
you see as a uniform D plus one bit
string and his hypothesis the D bit
string and he knows that the first bit
is zero so he doesn't need to worry
about that so if you just look at the
mutual information between the a and B
that has to be at least D because a good
learner has to learn a constant number
of bits of the target concept and then
the subadditivity you have the mutual
information of a and B has to be at
least at most T times the mutual
information between a and B one there is
a first pit and because I mean if you I
mean sort of if you look at this because
all the weight of the distribution lies
on s0 the probability of getting any
useful information together is just 4
epsilon over T times D because I mean
the useful information is on the last D
coordinates and they have a weight
overall or for epsilon sign if you just
put all these three things together you
have a sample complexity of lower bond
of T of D or Epsilon and when you look
at the quantum case in the third
statement you can hope for an upper
bound of at most just epsilon times D
over epsilon so you get a lower bound of
D or epsilon divided by log of D or
Epsilon
okay any any more questions
good so then let's thank again
[Applause]